ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mannschaft
welt und meine lieben freunde ich hoffe
ihr bleibt heute bis zum ende des videos
dran denn ich habe mir noch nie vor
einer episode minecraft mit lucca so
viele notizen aufgeschrieben ja die habe
ich wirklich bitter nötig denn ihr wird
bereits im titel eingeblendet
ja mein mund ist einigermaßen wieder
verheilt ihr seht bereits im titel
eingeblendet meine lieben freunde denn
wir kümmern uns heute um die village
insel und wir werden die upgraden auf
die willicher insel 2.0 da meiner
ansicht nach allerdings bauen immer das
langweiligste einer voll gemeinschaft
mit luca ist würde ich sagen fahren wir
als erstes mal da ganz hinten wieder zu
unserer villiger insel und holen uns
einen neuen villiger weil der der hier
war der es irgendwie nicht mehr da bevor
wir das allerdings tun könnt ihr mir mal
ganz kurz in die kommentare schreiben ob
ihr hier eine brücke seht ich hab da ja
gerade sonnenweg mit seerosen blättern
aber ihr könnt mir mal unten in die
kommentare schreiben
ob ich da eventuell in einer der
nächsten folgen eine brücke hin bauen
soll
[Musik]
darunter sind wir auch schon bei dem
wasser dorf hier vorne angekommen ihr
seht schon hier vorne das schaf wartet
immer noch auf mich die sache ist
allerdings dass wir das schaf auf jeden
fall holen werden sobald ich die tier
insel angehen werde also dann werden wir
das schaf auf jeden fall holen ich weiß
ich habe ich hier vorne noch was drin
habe was ich gebrauchen könnte für heute
das hier und das nehme ich mit ich kann
theoretisch sogar einfach mal alles
mitnehmen weil ich jetzt ja gerade auch
den platz habe und dann können wir auch
die kiste jemand mit abbauen
die sache ist was sich nämlich auch noch
von hier brauche ist die glocke das
womöglich und in die kommentare
geschrieben und zwar ist es eigentlich
ganz geil weil dann kann ich die
mitnehmen und immer wenn ich heim
perfekt immer wenn ich diese glocke dann
an berühre glocken läuten immer wenn ich
an der glocke läute dann wissen die
villiger hey wir müssen uns zu unseren
betten bewegen und das ist eigentlich
ganz gut um die dann mal so ein bisschen
auf trab zu halten wo sind denn hier
will just jetzt einfach mal hier vorne
hin hier sind auf jeden fall ein paar
villiger mehr und ich glaube dass ich
ihn einfach easy hier einschieben kann
so dass er sich jetzt daran setzt genau
wir haben den willicher drin wir haben
die glocke mit am start und noch mal
ganz kurz dann plötzlich zurück zu
meiner insel fahre so da sind wir wieder
hier vorne angekommen ich halt mal
direkt hier vorne an und geh ins den
schlafen denn ich habe keinen bock ich
habe keinen bock dass irgendwelche
zombies ankommen und unsere winter
wieder töten wir haben ja auch allein
schon vier oder fünfmal dorfbewohner aus
dem wasser dorf hinten geholt und die
sind alle verschwunden
ich werde mich jetzt allerdings auf
jeden fall bevor ich den winter hier
raus lassen auf die insel packe darum
kümmern dass wir eine vernünftige
umgebung für die hier erst mal schaffen
von daher ganz kurze teilnimmt wie ich
erstmal eine menge erde abbaue
[Musik]
so ich habe hier gerade wirklich zehn
minuten lang also einen kompletten
minecraft tag lang abgebaut ihr seht
schon die ganze erde insel hier ist
ziemlich zerrupft die sache ist
allerdings sie benötigen das ganze
einfach weil ich meine insel da hinten
also diese villiger insel direkt
eingeblendet seht im bild einfach mal so
ein bisschen unter erden möchte ich weiß
nicht ob das das richtige wort dafür ist
allerdings ist es ja oft so gewesen dass
wir ihnen wie ein block abgebaut haben
dann sind wir runter gefallen waren
direkt unter wasser
dann sind die village am rand nicht
richtig hoch gekommen weil die blöcken
ja ein höher sind und man keine glocke
im wasser hat also das wollte ich noch
ein bisschen anpassen auf jeden fall wir
haben ja auch noch entspannt aus bei
euch beiden damen ich würde allerdings
sagen dass ich mich jetzt ganz kurz hier
vorne wieder hinstelle den village
einmal ganz groß da drin lassen
[Musik]
das ist ein hausboot dann kannst du
schlapp ist mir auch egal ich gehe hier
vornherein auf jeden fall und werde mich
kurz hinlegen und euch dann jetzt
tatsächlich nochmal eine timeline landon
wie ich meine komplette erde nehme und
die komplette insel hier endlich mal
vernünftig unter erde
so ich habe gerade wirklich acht oder
neun stacks erde in einem dreiviertel
minecraft tag hier komplett verbaut ich
habe die insel auch mal ein bisschen
erweitert denn wir brauchen wirklich ne
menge platzwahl ist was wir heute machen
wollen und hier unten ist nun geht
runter ist nun alles unter erdet worden
und wir haben nun hier eine insel die
wirklich sich auch insel nennen kann
wenn ich jetzt den bock abbau ist es
nicht mehr so dass man jetzt hier ins
wasser reinfeldt sondern man befindet
sich noch auf der insel und wenn irgend
welche village runterfallen von der
insel können sie auch hierüber jetzt
ganz easy einfach wieder drauf klettern
und das habe ich überall rings um die
insel herum gemacht dass sie auf jeden
fall schon mal deutlich besser aus
dementsprechend da die sonne allerdings
schon fast wieder untergeht würde ich
euch jetzt erst mal ganz kurz zeigen was
ich heute alles vorhabe denn ich möchte
auf jeden fall diesen baum hier vorne
abfällen denn wir brauchen wirklich eine
menge platz für alles was ich heute
bauen möchte ich habe total bock auf die
heutige episode denn ich habe mir
wirklich noch nie und das beginnt schon
gesagt so viele notizen gemacht ich
möchte diesen kompletten bambus hier
abbauen denn den benötigen wir wirklich
eigentlich absolut überhaupt nicht der
einzige grund warum man muss in
minecraft braucht es entweder wenn man
irgendwas damit bauen will da ist mir
bisher noch nicht so richtig eingefallen
oder wenn man irgendwas mit solchen
halterungen machen möchte also
irgendwelche hohen bauwerk und da kann
man darüber hoch und runterklettern das
haben wir allerdings auch erst mal nicht
vor ich werde auch hier vorne
die farm abbauen da fragt euch jetzt
auch wahrscheinlich luca zufolge ist sie
mit dem baum und somit der farm jahr die
wird hier auch bleiben sagte es
allerdings dass die farben einen blog
höher werden soll also ich möchte die so
ein bisschen angeben so dass sie nie
warum gebe ich mir eigentlich die mühe
für euch ja ich möchte die farbe auf
jeden fall einen blog höher machen damit
die hier so richtig schön stattfinden
kann und ich möchte den weg ja auch so
ein bisschen weiter fortführen denn wir
werden ja auch noch ein neues häuschen
heute hin bauen wir werden hier und hier
einen neuen brunnen
stellen wir vorne wird die farbe
hinkommen ich werde dieses gebäude hier
ziemlich krass umbauen das wird sehr
sehr geil aussehen
ich werde auch das hier ein bisschen
umbauen allerdings würde ich ja ich
geschlafen und besorgt alle sachen die
wir für die willicher insel 2.0
benötigen
oh mein gott 15 minuten war ich gerade
unterwegs und habe mit diese ganzen
sachen die zusammen betrachtet sieht
zwar nicht so viele aus ist ist
allerdings extrem viel und es hat so
lange gedauert von daher kann ich euch
jetzt endlich zeigen wo wir das neue
aussehen bauen werden das kommt nämlich
hier vorne hin
dementsprechend mache ich ganz kurz eben
noch mal das ganze gras weg und wir
setzen das so hin dass wir hier ein
zweiter zwischen frei haben also hier
eine treppe hin die kommen jetzt hier so
hug und sagt es ist auch noch nicht
fertig die hier war nur so provisorisch
erstmal allerdings soll das ganze haus
hier vorne aussehen wie das ganze haus
hier sollen ein bisschen aussehen wie
ein fass habe ich mir gedacht und
dementsprechend soll es auch von der
seite so aussehen als wird das so ein
bisschen so hier in der luft schweben
das hier vorne ist der eingang dann
kommt man hier quasi so hoch hier vorne
machen wir 123 fichtenholz spengel
hinein 23 denn hier 1234 platz und hier
vorne kannst dann auch schon wieder rum
gehen dass wir keine riesiges haus
allerdings kommen dort vier betten rein
so dass wir endlich mal ein bisschen
platz haben so dass wir endlich mal ein
bisschen platz haben so dass sich diese
ganzen leute hier so ein bisschen zur
ruhe kommen lassen können tun und auch
ein bisschen kuscheln können alle
miteinander hier vorne kommen die teile
so hin die hab ich jetzt andere wieder
falsch gesetzt ich stehe total neben der
spur ich bin schon bei eineinhalb
stunden und wir sind in der folge
wahrscheinlich gerade erst mal bei
irgendwie 5
oder so weil ich schon so viele taxis
gemacht habe um die ganzen sachen
zusammen zu sammeln allerdings seht ihr
schon ich habe wirklich eine menge
fichtenholz holen müssen weil das hier
sind diese stämme dafür habe ich mir
auch dicker das ist noch nicht fertig
[Musik]
dann wohnst du halt woanders so hier
vorne kommen die stämme auch noch hin
und hier kommen dann auch fenster rein
dafür habe ich extra schwarze
glasscheiben genommen weil ich die
tatsächlich ein bisschen schöner finde
mittlerweile als die normalen
glasscheiben weil die so ein bisschen
getönt hat sind das habe ich hinter der
villa so ein bisschen lieben gelernt und
hier vorne den boden mache ich auch
nicht bis zum boden hin sondern dass
alles ein bisschen in der luft schweben
genauso wie von außen so dass sich das
ihnen so ein bisschen wieder findet hier
vorne platzieren wird zac und zeigt eine
treppe hin und hier zack zack das ist
falsch und sagte die hier bei euch mal
ganz kurz wieder ab und setzt sie auch
so hin denn hier zwischen soll nun eine
fichtenholz tür rein und auch noch
fichtenholz falltüren hier von der seite
die sollen nämlich so und so dass das
ganze haus von außen so aussieht das
dach des hauses hier vorne soll wie
folgt aussehen und zwar habe ich mir
dafür hier schon züchten holztreppen
gemacht die kommen jetzt nämlich zack
und sagt hier das ist ja falsch mache
das man doch lieber von ihr ausgeht
glaube ich ein bisschen einfacher die
sollen nämlich einmal so hier rum gehen
hier ist jetzt der komposter natürlichem
weg und sagt ja auch noch mal drum herum
das ist einfach beziehungsweise hat
einfach den grund weil ich da dann so
ein bisschen das dach habe genauso wie
hier vorne mit den fichten holztreppen
untätig abi nicht hin zu dumm nicht
antworten
das kann sich gar nicht ausdenken
ich wollte halt wirklich früher mal
architektur studieren alter ich bin so
und so die letzte treppe hier vorne
jetzt nehmen wir unsere laternen und
machen erstmal ein bisschen beleuchtung
dran das soll nämlich so ein bisschen
aussehen habe ich mich so ein bisschen
an so weiß nicht bei uns zuhause
bielefeld gibt es ein asiatisches
restaurant die haben auch an jeder ecke
sondern laterne hängt das nicht
eigentlich mal ganz schön und ich finde
man kann von licht den nie genug haben
in minecraft hier drinnen sieht es noch
nicht so schön aus er wollte mir ganz
gesund provisorische sonder treppe hoch
dass hier vorne kann ich auch noch mal
eben abbauen und hier kommt jetzt das
dach drauf dafür platzieren wir hier
außenrum erstmal ganz normale
fichtenholz bretter zack und zack und
hier nun die fichten holzstufen damit
dass alles noch ein bisschen luftiger
wird hier vorne die reihe zu ende hier
die reihe zu ende
und hier vorn aber noch 1 2 3 4 5 6 und
hier vorne drauf auch noch mal ein 23 12
13 2 das war falsch sagt und jena mit 1
2 dann können wir das hier ganz normal
eben wieder abbauen
dass sie wird das dach auf jeden fall
sein und von drinnen sich das ganze
jetzt gerade noch so aus daneben aber
ganz kurz mal eben die erde hier wieder
weg das sieht echt geil auch mit den
schwarzen glasscheiben finde ich weil
das ausland alles ein bisschen getönt
ist allerdings nehmen wir hierfür jetzt
auch unsere pflichten holztreppen
platzieren die so und so das gute ist
dass wir jetzt hier diese kleine diese
kleine lücke haben wo wir jetzt auch
noch mal zwei laternen platzieren könnte
mich hier vorne und da haben wir ein
bisschen licht hier drin und ihr seht
schon ich habe hier eine menge betten
gemacht denn das hier soll so ein
bisschen eine kleine jugendherberge
werden also hier sollen die alle
schlafen können und sich dann quasi mehr
hinlegen und halt einfach dass sie
wissen dass sie hier leben und nicht da
hinten in meinem baumhaus sowie der
andere typ da oben die ganze zeit herum
läuft und was ich mir auch noch gemacht
habe ist ein schmelzofen und ein
schleifstein die werde ich nämlich hier
vorne hinsetzen einmal hier und einmal
noch hier drauf so dass irgend jemand
den wir ja hier vorne im brötchen haben
vielleicht am besten der hier sogar
dass der den beruf dort vorne annimmt
und dementsprechend rüstung und auch
diamant gegenstände waffen etc handeln
kann gegen es mag denn viele smaragde
haben allerdings noch gar nicht so
richtig angefangen mit dem trading von
daher lasse ich ihn jetzt erstmal hier
raus hier direkt mein brötchen mit und
hoffe dass er jetzt hier vorne hingeht
und sich dort einen beruf snackt daumen
drücken
er ist oben er sieht das häuschen er
geht rein
wir haben es geschafft leute und wisst
ihr was wir jetzt auch machen können wir
können unser brot nehmen und das
aufteilen schmerzen hier acht brot ich
will das nicht
das tut mir auch unten in die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich gar nicht 30 brote
hinschmeißen soll sondern jeder braucht
einfach acht stück kommen er hat die auf
gesammelt um ihnen schmeiße ich nochmals
80 bekennen er sammelt auch auf das
heißt die beiden müssten sich jetzt guck
mal das schwert da oben das ist so
brutal beiden müssten sich doch jetzt
warum macht ihr nichts ja da habe ich
aber keine zeit für heute unter meiner
letzten folge haben übrigens auch ganz
ganz viele leute die kommentare
geschrieben und dafür wollte ich mich
auch ganz kurz mal bedanken dass das
eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm war mit
meiner lippe und das ist mir ehrlich
gesagt auch im schnitt nachher
aufgefallen
also ich hab dann riesig großen hehl
draus gemacht und dachte halt irgendwie
das geht gar nicht klar mit meiner lippe
ist tut mir leid ich musste meinen mund
zensieren und so weiter und so fort
allerdings war es schlussendlich gar
nicht mal so schlimm und ich hab mich
dann auch so ein bisschen blöd gefühl
dass ich das so auf dem video erwähnt
habe aber es war halt ohne die kamera an
zu haben wirklich schlimmer aus als dann
schlussendlich im video aber danke auf
jeden fall für eure ganzen
genesungswünsche unter dem letzten video
und auch danke für euer riesiges
feedback unter dem letzten video das hat
mich wirklich sehr gefreut wir waren
einfach in den deutschen youtube trends
auf dem verdammten ersten platz vor
irgendwelchen rebhan die ihre
monatelange musik rausgebracht haben
dann und so weiter und so fort ich habe
mich da wirklich schlecht gefühlt dass
wir mit so einer ganz normalen minecraft
situation hier plötzlich in den main in
den youtube trends sind wir waren das
angesagteste video in deutschland an dem
tag und das habe ich wirklich das ist
unfassbar und da wollte ich mich einfach
mal für euren riesigen support bedanken
freunde ich habe hier vorne gar keine
wert bank ist mir gerade aufgefallen
ich brauche allerdings eine werkbank um
mir noch ein bisschen fichtenholz falten
zu machen das hat schon gesehen ich habe
dort nämlich meine farben gerade schon
mal so ein bisschen angefangen das heißt
hier vorne mal ganz kurz eben 234 mehr
brauche ich sogar tatsächlich 16 stück
20 stück sollten auf jeden fall reichen
und die hacke muss sich auch mitnehmen
zack und die kerne habe ich glaube ich
nebenan alle auf der insel
denn ich möchte die ganze verein schon
gesagt so ein bisschen höher setzen und
dafür möchte ich die so ein bisschen
abtrennen und dafür habe ich mir diese
fichtenholz fall turnier gemacht zack
zack zack zack alle die neu sind beim
projekt werde sich wahrscheinlich denken
hill luca war machst alles verzichten
häufig liebe fichtenholz einfach ich
finde fichtenholz ist das schönste
material in minecraft dass man irgendwie
benutzen kann
hier vorne soll es allerdings nicht sein
den wir mal ganz kurz weg und hier an
der seite bauen wir auch noch mal eben
kurz den bambus ab der bambus soll
nämlich nur hier vorne links bei dem
aktien baum so ein bisschen wachsen weil
er mir doch ein bisschen zu groß wurde
den wirklich kann ich noch mal ein
bisschen weiter bauen die ganze insel
wird ja also ein dauerprojekt auch seien
die soll sich immer weiter erweitern so
dass wir schlussendlich irgendwann hier
unsere komplette eigene insel haben
unser eigenes dorf was wir uns selbst
ein bisschen quasi aufgebaut haben und
hier kommt dann quasi erst mal die farm
hin wo ich das ganze jetzt auch wie
folgt anordnen werde ich freue mich so
unfassbar dollar bei der heutigen
episode meine lieben freunde die kann
wirklich 101 in meiner lieblings folgen
in das projekt minecraft mit luca bisher
allerdings die bereits ich habe hier
vorne mir da gedacht dass ich hier
zweimal eine filmreihe mit weizen hin
mache dann hier einen melonen kehren und
dann habe ich ja auch noch einen
kürbiskern hier vorne so dass wir dann
immer so eine melone stehen haben und
hier so einen kürbis und hier auf die
seite habe ich mir gedacht dass ich dort
kartoffeln anpflanzen komplett also hier
komplett kartoffeln hier komplett weizen
und hier melonen und kürbisse die sache
ist allerdings dass ich fast keine
kartoffeln mehr hatte deswegen werde ich
mal ganz kurz hier so ein bisschen das
alles so ein bisschen spritzen hier
mitten im knochenmehl dass wir hier von
ein paar mehr haben zack zack zack zack
den kartoffeln ist wirklich ein
hauptnahrungsmittel in minecraft die
ganzen anderen sachen packe ich mal hier
rein und auch ein bisschen knochenmehl
die kartoffeln behalte ich rote beete
habe ich jetzt nicht angepflanzt weil
ich die ganze zeit nicht so richtig
wusste wofür ich über brauche was ich
damit machen kann ich glaube zum trading
ist die ganz gut aber so sollte das erst
mal reichen also das hier ist unsere
neue fan ich werde hier vorne auch noch
fackel
die sonne geht schon wieder unter ich
sage euch am ende wie lange ich
aufgenommen habe aber das ist nicht mehr
feierlich gerade so ich hab euch gerade
noch mal ganz kurz apps eingeblendet
denn ich habe mir gerade die sachen
geholt die ich für meine neuen begründen
oder bekunden ist dass die mehrzahl ich
weiß es nicht auf jeden fall benötige
denn ich vermisse ehrlich gesagt so ein
bisschen in brunnen und unsere semi
automatische fahren die wir da hinten
haben ich finde ihn sehr deutlich
schöner weil wir wirklich nicht so viel
essen benötigen wir dort immer uns
angepflanzt hat und wir wollen noch ein
bisschen nachhaltig leben
allerdings vermisse ich den boden so ein
bisschen ich fand ihn nämlich ganz schön
den hype pixel da gebaut hatte da hab
ich mich also ein bisschen daran
orientiert und den ganzen möchte ich
jetzt auch noch mal hierhin bauen einmal
hier zack und auch noch mal ich mach
doch gerade das ist ja alles wieder zu
gras wurde das auch sehr schnell
gegangen sehr geil und ich möchte den
gleichen boden auch nochmal hier vorne
hin bauen denn ich finde ein brunnen
kann nicht schaden aber zwei brunnen
können noch viel weniger schaden und wir
hatten ja auch damals in den brunnen
einen schleifstein drin der eigentlich
eher dekorative elemente mit sich
brachte die sache ist allerdings dass
wenn wir neue wille german und dann der
sich eventuell auf den schleifstein
konzentriert das wäre dementsprechend
dem beruf bekommt und dem anderen wohnen
werde ich auch keinen schleifstein
reinsetzen sondern die glocke das können
dann auch mal testen ihr seht auch schon
gerade ich weiß immer noch ganz genau
wie sie wohnen funktionieren damit eines
der ersten ästhetischen design projekte
die ich in diesem minecraft projekte
generell hatte hier vorne die
die stein ziegelmauern darauf und die
hier vorne auch also ich baue jetzt
quasi zweimal einfach komplett das
gleiche auf die stein ziegelmauern
kommen dann hier diese fichtenholz teile
drauf und hier vorne auf zack zack zack
zack und da drauf jetzt 14 fichtenholz
treppen auch noch mal ganz schnell da
muss ich mich an der seite eben einmal
ganz kurz hoch bauen und auf der anderen
seite hier vorne auch noch mal eben
leute ich bin wirklich unfassbar wie
kriegt das jetzt allerdings müssen wir
als einmal ganz kurz durch und nachher
wird auf jeden fall richtig geil
aussehen also die treppen hier sind
fertig die hier vorne kann nicht abbauen
und dazwischen kommen nun sich den
holzstufen neben nicht satt zack zack
hier noch eine und darauf auch noch mal
eben kurz welche nämlich einmal kurz
hierüber gesamte zack und zack und wir
vorne auch noch mal eine fichtenholz
stufe hin die habe ich mir gerade mal
eben noch mal neu betrachtet hier vorne
hängen wir jetzt den schleifstein daran
und an dem schleifstein runter die
kettengliedern hier unten rein gehen
jetzt fehlt nur noch das wasser das habe
ich mir schon ein eimer mitgenommen das
kann jetzt einfach ihr nehmen und hier
rein platzieren und dann den zweiten
aber wasser noch verein und auch den
dritten auch und damit den ersten wohnen
schon der erste brunnen ist jetzt auf
jeden fall fertig genau das gleiche
werden die jetzt ja auch noch auf der
anderen seite bauen das heißt ich baue
ich auch eben einmal ganz kurz hoch
nehmen meine fichtenholz treppen setzte
die hierhin dann hier an die seite
müssen wir uns einmal kurz die so
bisschen jackie chan mäßig an der seite
her bauens man merkte ich
mehr als zwei stunden auf ich glaube
dass man das im video immer nie so
richtig mitbekommen wie lange ich
wirklich aufnehmen weil voll häufig sehe
ich auch kommentare von leuten so
schreiben die kasseler aufnehmen das
video geht doch nur 20 minuten ja ich
weiss allerdings arbeite ich hab viel
metall bleibt es nicht schneiden auch
immer ganz viel
einige werfen immer vor luca wer
schneidet dann schiebt er uns so aber
ich verstehe dass immer nie so richtig
so was soll s mir selbst einbringen wenn
man schüttet ich glaube ich jeder der
irgendwie mal gta oder irgendwelche
spiele gespielt hat wo es wirklich um
die story gingen also klar bei minecraft
jetzt nicht um eine richtige story aber
das spiel wird ganz ganz schnell
langweilig wenn man sich selbst kaputt
macht dadurch dass man schüttet deswegen
würde ich so was halt einfach nie machen
und möchte einfach den spaß aus dem bc
hydro aufrechterhalten
und wir haben ja auch keinen zeitdruck
also ob ich jetzt keine ahnung das video
ein bisschen länger aufnehme oder mir
irgendwie dazwischen dann irgendwas
mache was ich eh nicht machen werde dann
das macht aber keinen sinn was ich kann
alles sage ihr wisst aber durch was ich
meine ich werde mich jetzt allerdings
hier so ein bisschen anders
konzentrieren bei der ganzen sache denn
eigentlich kommt er jetzt hier
fichtenholz stufe dran und dann darunter
auch sonst stand und die kette da hab
ich mir allerdings gedacht dass wir die
glocke ja cool integrieren müssen von
daher einfach eine kette und da die
glocke dran hier die stufe nehme ich mir
mal eben und auch meinen wassereimer
beziehungsweise meinen normalen heime
und fülle dort neben ganz kurz wasser
rein so dass wir das auch hier vorne
haben
[Musik]
was habe ich getan
jetzt funktioniert auf jeden fall also
ich hab
[Musik]
dieser trend nicht da die sonne
allerdings schon wieder untergeht würde
ich sagen geben die haben zwei kinder
na gut morgen war ein kleiner ausflug in
der jugendherberge ist klappt auf jeden
fall richtig richtig gut mit den betten
hier und das freut mich extrem die
ganzen stehen auf und sind wach wie es
kommt auf jeden fall leben hier rein wie
vor niemand drin geschlafen mir hier
nicht hat hier jemand drin geschlafen
hat er darin geschlafen als wir haben 1
2 erwachsene und 2 kinder die hier oben
spielen kommen hier könnt euch bisher de
perfekt
ich weiß nicht was ich hier falsch
gebaut habe ich baue das man einmal ganz
kurz noch mal eben hier abzocke und auch
hier vorne mal eben kurz die fichtenholz
stufe abbauen und hier die erde hin
ich weiß nicht was ich irgendwie falsch
gemacht habe das ach so ich habe glaube
ich in die stufe wasser eingesetzt das
hatte ich glaube ich auch bei meinem
ersten brunnen den ich damals gebaut
hatte dass sich das wasser falsch
anvisiert hatte oder irgendwie so also
ich muss wirklich auf dem boden das
ganze richten dienstag sack und pack
dann sollte das ganze funktionieren dann
sehen jetzt auch schon dass wir diesen
brunnen fertig haben und diesen brunnen
hier können wir jetzt am schleifstein
bisschen was reparieren und entzaubern
damit kenne ich mich noch nicht so
richtig aus
das tipps habt schreibt gerne und in die
kommentare aber hier haben jetzt das
hier machen
ihr seht schon jeder geht rein in sein
haus und das hört auch er da oben also
erst erledigt seinem einem baumhaus drin
aber jeder weiß dann quasi er es kommt
irgendwie war es keine ahnung was pipapo
und deswegen dachte ich dass das
vielleicht ganz gut wenn wir hier an die
glocke habe und ihr den schleifstein
dann ist das hier so ein bisschen so der
boden und das ist dann so der
mittelpunkt und keine ahnung was genau
die laternen wäre ich ganz kurz mal hier
vorne dran hängen denn das pflanzen
beziehung
hier sollen keine kartoffeln oder rote
beete war daher sollte die melone
wachsen das erwächst natürlich deutlich
schneller wenn hier nicht so richtig
dran kommt deswegen habe hier so eine
menge nicht wir haben hier liegt hier
bei den brunnen brauchen jetzt glaube
ich nicht ich werde mir allerdings
generell mal meine stein ziegelmauern
nehmen und hier einfach mal überall noch
so ein bisschen laternen hinsetzen so
dass wir ein bisschen mehr beleuchtung
haben wir haben hier zwar auf der insel
hier vorne schon da sollst du nicht hin
wir haben auf der insel hier vorne 2
schuy 2.0 der ja so ein bisschen
aufpasst allerdings kann nicht trotzdem
nicht schaden hier vorne das sollte
eigentlich genug sein glaube ich hier
vorn um die ecke rum hier können wir mal
einen eben hinsetzen und vielleicht noch
mal hier vorne irgendwie auf ecke so
hier
das nicht kommen lassen dass ich glaube
das sollte auf jeden fall reichen mit
der beleuchtung vielleicht hier vorne
noch so ein bisschen hier oder so und
dann geht hier der fliegt damit war sie
irgendwann mal weiter das habe ich auch
so ein bisschen angedeutet dass auf
jeden fall noch weiter gehen soll
mit der insel allerdings haben wir
wirklich schon eine menge geschafft ich
werde jetzt mal ganz kurz bommel holen
das hier ein bisschen auf dem boden
packen
[Musik]
so dass das hier vorne auch alles so ein
bisschen verbuchte aussieht und
dementsprechend alles so ein bisschen
zum rest von unserer ganzen welt passt
hier vorne auch noch mal so ein bisschen
rum das recht müssen zu verbuchen
aber hier vorne dann so ein bisschen
hier um die ecke noch mal drauf klicken
und hier so ein bisschen dann sieht
alles ein bisschen schöner aussieht
findet immer ganz geil wenn das alles so
ein bisschen mit dem gras hier voll
gewachsen ist hier vorne um die ecke
auch noch und was ich machen wollte und
dafür seht ihr schon unten ich hab mir
wieder ein lagerfeuer abgebaut einzige
morgen reisen falsche und ein
schmelzofen denn das haus hier vorne
das ist ja auch irgendwie noch nicht so
das wahre und da habe ich mir jetzt
gedacht dass ich das hier vorne einfach
mal abbauen und werde da haben wir hier
das lagerfeuer und da werde ich auch
generell einfach mal da habe ich ja gar
nicht verstehen warum ich das hier oben
überhaupt aus diesem holz gemacht habe
weil das hier soll so ein bisschen ja
unsere stein hütte werden
deswegen werde ich erst mal diese
eichenholz stufen wir abbauen hier vorne
und auch den boden abbauen und jetzt
kommt die jedes jahr 1000 denn ich
möchte ich hier ein lagerfeuer hinsetzen
darüber den schmelzofen so dass der so
ein bisschen hochgeht
und dann möchte ich darüber allerdings
eine eisen falsche sätze und eine stein
ziegelmauer also das ist wirklich so ein
bisschen wie so ein ofen aussieht wie
hinten unserer modernen strandhaus villa
also das sieht wirklich sehr offen mit
so einer abzugshaube und hier oben kommt
dass dann sogar raus denn hier oben
haben wir ja noch ein lagerfeuer hin
platziert da habe ich mir allerdings
gedacht dass ich das hier nicht so schön
finde mit diesem ding das man das halt
sieht deswegen möchte ich hier vorne auf
jeden fall dieser stein zuge
mauersteinen maucksch bruchsteinmauer
abbauen und nicht eine buchstein stufe
ersetzen das sieht glaube ich ein
bisschen schöner aus von außen
ich hab's mir bisher nur ein attest welt
angeguckt aber ich glaube dass es auch
hier ganz gut aussehen könnte weil man
es nicht so richtig wahrnimmt
man denkt die hilfe kommt ende der
raucher und dann geht man rein und die
a-ha die ist noch offen
das tier vorne möchte ich dann so ein
bisschen vollmachten mit bruchsteinen
stufen und hier an die seite habe ich
mir gedacht da kommt keine laterne hin
sondern eine fackel weil ich finde eine
fackel passt irgendwie besser wenn ich
glaube ich sogar so hin
ich finde fackel passt besser zusammen
haus
wenn das visum alles steinig ist und so
ein bisschen ich weiß es nicht ich komme
immer gerne und in die kommentare
schreiben was ihr davon haltet das sie
haben jetzt quasi so ein bisschen neu
gemacht ich habe mir auch in neue
bruchsteinmauern gemacht ich möchte ich
nämlich auch komplett hochziehen
ich glaube das liegt ein bisschen
schöner aus wenn das dann einmal so
komplette umgeht und dementsprechend so
ein bisschen so einen runderen charakter
hat das ganze haus und das war es glaube
ich ich habe jetzt insgesamt zum
allerersten mal zwei stunden und 37
minuten aufgenommen
wenn euch meine lieben freunde das
heutige video gefallen hat dann würde
ich mich unfassbar dollar über einen
daumen hoch von euch unter dem video ihr
freund schreibt mir unten in die
kommentare
ob ich hier eine brücke hin bauen soll
oder ob es bei diesen mit rosenblättern
bleiben soll
und wenn ihr ja sagt also denn alle
schreiben ja da sollen eine brücke hin
lukas ich weiß nicht ich kann mir das
noch nicht so richtig vorstellen
aber wir können ja mal gucken und wenn
ihr da bock drauf habe dann werde ich
mich das fragt man dann partys 1
raussuchen
wenn ich das machen soll also wenn ich
da eine brücke hin waren soll soll das
dann übermorgen stattfinden in der neuen
folge minecraft mit nokia oder sollen
wir übermorgen eine neue erkundungstour
machen und mal dorthin fahren da hinten
befindet sicher dass hills biom und wir
sind noch nie weiter als das pils wie
umgegangen
also was soll ich in der übernächsten
folge wer in der nächsten folge machen
übermorgen soll ich eine brücke bauen
wenn er überhaupt bock drauf habt oder
solch eine erkundungstour machen
allerdings haben wir wirklich heute
extrem viel geschafft die bilder sind
schon erwachsen die haben verschiedene
berufe der jetzt eine rüstung schmid wir
haben einen waffenschmied wir haben hier
den bauer
ja die pflanzen sich schon wieder weiter
fort wir haben hier noch
die kriegen schon wieder ein klein ich
bin unfassbar happy es war bisher
wirklich meine lieblings folge des
kompletten projekt weil ich das einfach
liebe wenn man sachen cool kreativ
umsetzen kann wir haben hier den neuen
brunnen mit dem schleifstein dann wir
haben ja einen brunnen mit einer glocke
läuten dann gehen alle reihen in ihre
häuser wir haben die farben schöner
gebaut wir haben überall beleuchtung wir
haben hier zwei anstatt der aufpasst
erstes wirklich wahnsinnig geil geworden
die heutige episode es tut mir leid dass
ich noch immer nicht so richtig lachen
kann wegen meiner lippe allerdings meine
lieben freunde wie bereits gesagt lass
gerne einen daumen hoch und ein video
der abonniert main kanal als auch keinen
der lose seiten klicken auf die glocke
um die nächste folge über morgen um 20
uhr nicht zu verpassen ich habe mich
liebte sie
[Musik]